How would we know if our cancer is active or not? Would a clean mammogram tell us that?
um
Maybe personally I wouldn't do a mammogram at all anyhow because that radiation you certainly if you had breast
Obviously you're thinking of breast cancer
The radiation would not be good for breast cancer
So how would you know if you have breast cancer and you that your cancers active or not?
Well you look at all sorts of different subjective and objective findings
When your cancer when you know when you knew your cancer was active, how did you know that
You've found a lump. It was growing
You went to the doctor and you had positive objective findings with your
biopsy you had positive findings with your
uh the MRI or the CT scanner or the PET scan
And
And you decided on a course of treatment whether that was a blend of alternative in standards or was all alternative
And you're you feel like you're doing better
Subjectively you don't have any signs or symptoms that you can subjectively relate to the cancer growing
But how do I know if I'm better
Objectively? Well, we could go back to the scans. So it depends on how invasive one wants to be
um
If we go back to the scans that is MRIs PET scans and CT scans
MRI typically is going to have to be done with a
Contrastine which is catalytic which can be invasive come people don't detoxify it well
And a book catalytic and toxicity so long I guess I don't want to really do that
Even more invasive is the CT scan which is going to give you enough radiation of about 50 chest X raise
Oh, I don't want to do that
Same about a radiation with the PET scan
Well, I don't really want to do that, but that's going to be your most
You know beneficial if you're going to try to measure apples to apples if you didn't MRI or CT scan or PET scan
To diagnose it in the first place
Then you in order to absolutely know comparing to apples to apples you'd have to do that same scan
Well, some people will go yes, I want to do that because I want to know
You have to know that it does carry you know it here at risk
I'm willing to go through that risk. I need to know if I'm doing better or not doing better
Okay, that's great if that helps with your anxiety levels and by all means that's the best way is to compare apples to apples
I do have videos on this on our member side as well. How do I know if I'm getting better? I think it's the name of the video
But you could do other less invasive things do some blood work. There's ominous signs in blood work
Yeah, my liver markers. Okay. It's my calcium markers. Okay
Are
L.I. Developed in anemia. Oh, no, I had some anemia, but that's much better
Okay, well, you know if things have changed for the better in standard blood work by
That I mean your CBC and comprehensive metabolic panel and things have changed for the better
That's a very good sign
So everything you have to take in pieces and everything is a clue to what's going on
And then you could look at tumor marker tests
Well, I never did tumor marker tests. Well then doing a baseline tumor marker test. We've been official
So with breast cancer, you do a CA 153 a CA 199 a CA 27 29 a CEA
LDH
Those would be some tumor marker tests and you'd find that in our store under the female tumor marker panel
Writing a blood simple blood test that a tumor marker panel can
Give you a baseline. Let's say all of those are within normal range
Well, we didn't know what they were before. Maybe they were high before
If this was your first one and maybe they've come back to normal that we would know
So I always think it's good to get a baseline of that even if you feel like you're doing great
Because now you could use that. Hey, that's another indication
My CBC is great. My complete metabolic profile is great
My tumor marker panel is great. I don't have any signs or symptoms. I can't feel the mass hasn't grown at all
Okay, well then I would say I'm probably gonna
I just claim that I'm in a state of remission of doing well
By my symptoms were worse
For me personally by symptoms were much worse. They were really bad at one time
When I was sure I wasn't gonna make it till Christmas and then I ended up doing a pro nouveau scan
Which is a different type of MRI that doesn't use a contrast die
The only negative of that is insurance doesn't cover it yet to be cash for it
And there's in the only other negatives is I think there's really seven of them in the whole United States
But I was fortunate that there was what in Minneapolis
So I did the pro nouveau scan and it just showed a few tubers in my liver that were left
And I was happy just to say okay. God is healing me. There wasn't anything in my
colorectal area what I did that scan now at the time that is that scan
I was feeling you know
100 times better. I was feeling like I was you know
You know in remission when I did that scan and I am not doubted again that was
This will be four years coming up. I think I can't remember I lose track of time when I think back
but um it's um
And I haven't had any of the symptoms again now my cancer
I I displayed very distinct symptoms
It's just thinking of that today because I was talking to a different patient. I was thinking yeah
I haven't any of those symptoms
For at least four years
so um
Other symptoms because my body's getting old but not those symptoms. So
I've said to you guys. I've said to other people and I don't even think of my cancer anymore
I feel like I'm in complete remission and
so I
Just go on with that. It if God takes me home tomorrow then um
I'm much better because of it. So that's okay